hi my name is sweet white I work in
public relations here at Wolfram
research today my presentation is on
correlations between Bitcoin tweets and
Bitcoin price
good morning everyone how is everyone
doing this morning bright and early here
in Champaign okay good my name is sweet
light I work here at Wolfram research in
the public relations department or as it
was dubbed last night the smiles
Department because we like to make
everyone smile and spread the very good
news of Wolfram research and our
products today I'm giving a presentation
analyzing correlations between Bitcoin
tweets that mention the hashtag BTC and
price trading price of Bitcoin so we're
going to be doing mainly kind of an
exploratory analysis looking at the kind
of quick fast prototyping capabilities
of Wolfram language so just in brief you
know as we all know social media
websites have become more and more
important especially in the last
presidential election Twitter is
becoming particularly kind of a real
time 24/7 area where the news is
discussed and it does have impacts
outside of social media in the past it
has been assumed that what happens on
social media kind of stays in that
sphere and it doesn't make its way kind
of out of that into you know reality so
to speak so what we're gonna do here is
use a little bit of natural language
processing and some time series analysis
to examine these correlations what we're
gonna do mainly is visualize it to see
if we can see any kind of trends between
sentiments and Bitcoin price so one
thing that's been going on in the past
five years I I used to be a PhD student
in sociology and I was very interested
in social media one thing that happened
frequently is that I would tell
professors I was interested in studying
reddit or something like that and they
would look at me and that's that's not
real research that that's not that's not
real data things of this nature and
there are some criticisms around that
and some of those I do want to address
when since we're using Twitter data is
that it's not necessarily representative
of the population so if we are going to
do any sort of statistical analyses we
have to keep that in mind that we can't
necessarily take what's on Twitter and
then generalize to the population at
large
so crypto currencies I'm assuming
everyone here is familiar with Bitcoin
and crypto currencies so back in around
2008 this figure Satoshi Nakamoto wrote
a white paper outlining blockchain and
the cryptocurrency Bitcoin the idea is
there is a ledger where you can
there's peer-to-peer transactions and
ideas to have it decentralized it has
the potential to not only disrupt how we
do banking how we do transactions but
also recently some claims the internet
itself so natural language processing I
if you've done it before you know
textual data is very messy we're dealing
with unstructured stuff we're not
dealing with nice tabular data or
spreadsheets one good thing about
Wolfram language is it has a lot of
built-in functions to help us clean up
our text and analyze it there's some new
stuff that Stephan outlines coming in
version 12 that is actually quite
exciting and it's one of our strengths
with Wolfram language and that should be
of no surprise given the success of
Wolfram Alpha being able to enter a
query into it and have it return
accurate results to you and for today
we're gonna look at kind of rapid
prototyping how quickly we can do
sentiment classification how quickly we
can visualize stuff really to kind of
test some assumptions or some hypotheses
to see if we should take it a step
further so if you ever have a research
question or something like that you can
wind up spending weeks trying to just
get started and figure it out one of the
advantages of working and Wolfram
language is that you can spend like a
half hour and get your work done and get
some answers ok so data collection for
this was tricky so we're gonna use
tweets with the hashtag BTC we could
have used it we can use the Twitter API
using service connect has anyone used
service connects with Twitter before you
have so you know you run into rate
limits with it right I think believe the
rate limits around 5,000 so you can set
up an automated task and have this
collect more frequently you can also use
the Twitter API firehose so I contacted
Twitter out of curiosity to see how much
it would cost to tap into their firehose
and it starts at $1,250 for a 40 day
period but it's a million tweets it's
quite a lot they do
have a complete history so let's say we
found something very interesting and our
analysis here we could go to Twitter and
buy this and do look at historically and
see what's going on we would be spending
quite a bit of money though so what I
did actually is use the wool from data
drop has anybody used to go from data
drop before okay so basically what I
have is I have if this than that setup
and this is a little applet I believe it
was made by Wolfram actually so you can
put in a hashtag and what it does
anytime that pops up its gonna dump it
into a data been that we can later call
for analysis
so what we have here is text and
timestamp and since it's collecting in
real time we don't have like and retweet
data but since we have the tweet ID we
can go back and find that so what we do
first is we import from our data Ben and
as you can see it returns this nice
object right here with all our
information we can see that we have one
hundred twenty-nine thousand eight
hundred seventy-three tweets that we are
going to be looking at these have been
collected since June 8th of this year so
then we have a nice data set and you can
see we have our tweets with our
timestamp and so what I've done here
we're just defining our time and our
text and so we're also gonna you need to
grab the bitcoin price so Wolfram Alpha
does have Bitcoin price and you can grab
it from Wolfram Alpha what it has though
is closing though so it only has each
one each day has the closing price what
I wanted to do is get a bit more
granular and get to the hourly level so
I went to a third-party website to grab
that so I've grabbed that here check our
dimensions and then we're gonna define
our dates price and I've also grabbed
volume because I'm kind of interested in
what's going on with volume as it
compares to sentiment on Twitter so we
have several options for kind of
breaking up chunks of text into
paragraphs sentence word letter its
stuttering Wolfram language since I'm
interested in the sentiment of each
tweet I'm gonna keep everything at the
tweet level but I'm gonna clean it up
just a little bit to remove stop words
and then also URLs so by default if
you've used the built in sentiment
classifier it's very simple
it returns values of positive negative
neutral what we're gonna do right here
is change those to 1 minus 1 and
determinant as 0 so we can better ease
with more easily visualize this so after
I've run my sentiment classifier we can
kind of take a quick look at it and see
what we have well open so we have a lot
of neutral that's likely because there
are still I didn't filter out as much as
I probably could have so we have a lot
of neutral going on but more positive
than negative for sure so now what we're
going to do is create a time series of
our sentiment values and time
and so what I've done here as well is
use mean filter to smooth some of this
out so if I did not apply this filter to
it and kind of do a moving average of
this we're gonna have a lot of noise and
not be able to see any kind of signal
going on in it so as you can see around
August if you'll recall Bitcoin price
went way up shot way up and kind of came
down so we can see our sentiment going
up right here you know what's
interesting and what will kind of get to
you is you know the question is what's
driving what we're not sure if sentiment
is driving the Bitcoin price or Bitcoin
price is driving the sentiment because
obviously if you own a lot of Bitcoin
and the price is going up you might
tweet about being very happy about it or
if it's going down you might tweet about
you know being kind of upset that you've
lost a bunch of money in cryptocurrency
so we're also going to run time series
of our Bitcoin price and as we did just
with sentiment we're gonna define price
volume but we've already defined time we
can also see as I mentioned around
August this huge spike as we did with
sentiment it looks like this is
happening just a little bit before the
sentiment on Twitter kind of rapidly
increased and so what I'm going to do
here is to visualize this is rescale so
I picked some fairly arbitrary numbers
here that I played around with to get
these all into one plot so what I've
done here is kind of redoing sentiment
and then plotted that with as it scaled
as though as you can see we have our
scaled sentiment core score Bitcoin
price and Bitcoin volume
what's interesting like I mentioned
right here is this spike in August and
then we see the sentiment score going up
but it's slightly correlated so I would
ask you in the audience what what do you
think is going on here
and what would you do going forward
anyone Carlo what do you think right so
we could what could we could do further
is do a time series model and see what
we could come up with that and look at
the direct correlations between what's
going on with the score and the price
then also the volume so I'm ending way
early if we've been able to quickly
prototype a time series with natural
language processing to see if there's
something worth exploring we could take
things further by gather and complete
Twitter data with more search terms and
then also identify influential accounts
on Twitter with search terms and network
analysis like I said we could also
create time series models to extract for
exact correlation values between our
sentiment and Bitcoin price does anyone
have questions